hello everyone and welcome to the
infectious disease virtual event my name
is Krishna Allen palem and I'm the
global marketing director at came by Oh
diagnostics and I am representing the
presentation on advances in
point-of-care testing for infectious
diseases please feel free to submit a
question C during my presentation and I
will follow up with you via email
compiler Diagnostics is a publicly
traded company hence we are obligated by
law to show you this safe harbor
statement just take a few seconds to
read through this okay that being done
let's move on to the very exciting part
of this webinar that is the first part
is the agenda we'll start off with an
introduction to point of care testing
then we will talk about the current
technology that is being used in point
of care testing that is lateral flow
then we'll introduce you to the new
innovative technology that is dual PLAs
platform also called DPP we'll talk
about the application of DPP technology
in point-of-care Diagnostics here the
applications will focus on infectious
diseases and after that we will talk
about the new exciting additions to DPP
technology this is a relatively short
presentation so you'll have ample time
to ask your question and answers I know
there are many definitions of
point-of-care testing but what is
point-of-care testing for us or how do
we look at it point-of-care testing is
an investigation that takes at the time
of consultation with instantly available
results so that the physician can make
immediate and informed decisions about
primary
patient care where does it happen most
often it will happen in a physician's
office and urgent care clinics walk-in
clinics in pharmacy clinics hospitals
like in the emergency rooms or in the
triage center and in mobile clinics or
field tests if you look at the first
group that is a physician all the way up
to hospitals this is a more controlled
environment you are in a room or in a in
a place whereas the last one is the
mobile or the field testing it is done
in a different environment
sometimes the tests are done in the back
of a car or it is done in a village in a
mobile clinic so a point-of-care test
the packaging and the design is to make
sure that it fits all these environments
some of the examples of point-of-care
testing include blood glucose drugs of
abuse screening infectious disease
screening such as strep a true RSV HIV
syphilis and many more what are the key
features of this point of care testing
the key features are first it has to be
simple and reliable well many a times
the testing is done not by physicians or
nurses it's just sometimes it done by
caseworkers or social workers but these
people are trained but certainly they're
not they we don't need to be a highly
educated to get a tool to do this kind
of test second is it should be accurate
sensitive and specific as you see on the
left hand side I actually showed you an
example of short chat HIV test this is a
very simple test and it's really
accurate and specific we have sold more
than 25 million tests will globally and
the sensitivity is about ninety-nine
point eight and a specificity is about
100 percent so these point-of-care tests
have to be accurate sensitive and
specific the third thing is it should be
short turnaround time they around 15
minutes
so that the doctors the physicians can
kill themselves as and when they are
when the patients are in their office
they should be self-contained it should
be portable and robust now this last two
points are critical self-contained
because if you're doing a tests in the
field if you need a pouch which has
everything including a band-aid a Lancet
a swab alcohol swab so that then the the
tester need not look for everything it
should be all self-contained in a
specific pouch portable and robust if
the pouch is small the the the tester
can have it in a bag and can easily
carry it from one place to another and
robust it doesn't matter whether it's in
a coal or in the heart on it is in the
trunk of a car
we're in Ethiopia where the degrees is
40 degree Celsius even in that situation
this test has to survive and perform
well the other features are multiplexing
capability what does that mean you are
able to test for HIV and syphilis or
Zika and Ebola and dengue in one single
test from one drop of blood that is
multiplexing on both sample conditioning
sometimes in a point-of-care test you
want to just look at ITM or IgG in that
case you should want to remove have the
ability to remove the ITM or the remove
the IgG from there and that is what is
called onboard sampling there are
multiple sample metric mattresses for
example we should be opposite position
to test for fingerstick blood or serum
or plasma whole blood or something from
the saliva or maybe stools or unit so
this test should be able to use in all
different matrices and most important is
the cost one of the reasons part of care
testing is becoming more and more
popular and being more used is because
of the low cost so that the doctors can
get the information quickly at low cost
now in some of the WTO has also defined
certain conditions or certain saying
that these are the conditions which a
point-of-care testing should resolve
should follow one is it should be
affordable sensitive specific
user-friendly rapid and robust equipment
free and deliverable to end-users and if
you take that it's also you can call it
I should
as you know WTO works in mostly in
resource-constrained settings like in
African countries or some of the rural
areas to contain epidemics so for them
the point-of-care testing has to follow
basically this specific pattern what are
the different type of samples which we
already covered is the sample types that
need to be covered are the whole blood
serum plasma or a fluid and stools now
what are the different analytes then a
point-of-care testing you know you take
a point a drop of blood what what can
you look for either you can analyze the
whole cells you can look at the nucleic
acids the DNA or the RNA or you can look
at the proteins the antigen and
antibodies the antigens for infectious
in from infectious agents such as tissue
specific biomarkers or biomarkers from
infectious agents for example influenza
nuclear proteins strep a or dengue in s1
or you can also look at antibodies
against infectious agents such as
screening for HIV TB ebola zika
chikungunya so what is this point of
care test what is this lateral flow
technology what is that if you look at
the diagram on the left hand side you'll
see that there is basically consists of
a medium it can be a nitrocellulose
medium and the sample is added as a
single drop of blood on the left hand
side a drop of lettuce added this
ample moves through capillary action
then the analyze the analyte specific
colored conjugate binds to the analyte
in the sample what does the analyte for
example if you are looking for an
antibody for HIV infection then you
actually get that analyte will bind to
this analyzed rosy colored conjugate and
this whole complex moves along the the
paper the night Ursula's paper and it
will it is captured by the analyte
specific molecules and that are in the
in the test and then an accumulation of
the colored complexes becomes visible
and that's the test lines becomes red or
whatever the color may be and it's just
shows a positive this a point-of-care
tests are very easy to use and this is
just about 10 to 20 minutes turnaround
time and these are fairly sensitive and
specific and I talked to you about the
sensitivity and specificity of this test
so these are the one-way lateral flow
tests just to give you an example of how
easy this is the short read HIV
self-test what we offer as audio to do
is prick your finger then collect the
sample in the testing device this is a
tube cut and then put it in a insert it
in a buffer well insert it in wait for
15 minutes and you'll get the results
it's a very simple three-step process
where you do prepare run and read as I
mentioned before the key features of
this point-of-care tests are as they are
simple one-step
fast low cost and low sample volume I
didn't mention that for sure check HIV
self-test you just need to point 5
microliters of blood a drop of blood is
about 50 to 60 meters whereas the EOTech
HIV cell test requires only 2.5
micrometers
sample volume is critical because many
times when you do the test especially in
the field people might not be hydrated
and it might not be in a position to get
that drop of blood out and that's why
this small volume is very a very
important key feature or point of care
testing again you can look for proteins
antibodies nucleic acids as I mentioned
and another important thing is these
point-of-care tests we should be easily
integrated into any of the workflows
what are the limitations of
point-of-care testing especially the
lateral flow technology the first step
is it's easy it's one step but it's no
washing possible and when that's so
washing possible what happens is you get
not a background number two is the
sample volume is limited by the sample
pad size capacity now if you look at the
diagram on the left hand side the sample
pad that size actually limits the amount
of sample you can add if you overload it
it will it will the analyte for example
the antibody will bind to everything and
it can already also call what we call at
the hook effect no hook effect is
basically low to no signal even though
the sample is positive it does so that
is one thing that can happen with
point-of-care especially with lateral
flow technology with all in another
thing is interference with the conjugate
after that is sample pretreatment is not
possible
now the size of this pad is so small
that's not possible to have any kind of
sample pretreatment here because if we
add anything to this small area then it
can interfere with not only with your
contact with your sample but it can also
interfere with the gold conjugate pad
which is a very small I know in the in a
picture it looks very big but actually
if you look at the at the sample at the
the tube one at the strip it's they're
very small then the ability to multiplex
is limited because when you have small
amount of samples then the chances are
and still and also small a very small
path to travel you're unable to
multiplex and oppose limited
quantitative asses quantitation so these
are the limitations you saw but what is
the current medical need the medical
need is versus is it new infectious
diseases and Co infection in patients
for example in case of HIV many times
people with HIV also have syphilis so it
is better to instead of making two
epochs and doing two different tests
it's better to have a single test
wherein you can test for both HIV and
syphilis diseases with similar
presentations differential diagnosis at
point of care is needed a person comes
in with a fever now we don't know
whether it's fever is because of
Wireless a bacterial or fungal infection
or something else and these things are
happening more often so what should you
do so this guy a great need to do
differential diagnosis like in in the
and right in the doctor's office that's
neat for triage
as you know the doctor's office if
you've been recently there you have to
wait a long time the doctors are busy
the physicians are busy a need for
multiplexing as I explained before
quantitation is there and also
integration into networks many tests are
done in tests are done in the field so
if that is the case so we need the
information to go from the field to the
to the central a data collection center
and from the data collection center
maybe to the Public Health Office so
connectivity is very critical and this
connectivity is of course done between
the tests to a cell phone and from the
cell phone it goes to the wearable other
collection data collection centers this
collection is important especially if
you're monitoring a specific epidemic in
a rural part of Africa
so with these needs in lateral
technology Kimbra diagnostics came up
with this new and innovative platform
it's called the dual path platform what
is so nice about this thing is that it
has two parts first one for sample and
other for conjugate the sample is on the
lower part of the on the if you look at
the the cartridge or the cassette on the
left-hand side you'll see the sample is
on the on one side where the sample will
move towards the testing window where
and the conjugate will also will come
from the other side so there are two
separate facts the whole process is very
much like an Alaia like process where
you add a sample and in the end the
sample travels from this end towards the
test line or the test window we can
condition it we can do we can do some
pretreatment and before the conjugate
binds to the test lines the we give a
lot of time for the enter life or the
antibody to buy into the capturing
antigen and only after it binds and we
give it five minutes to do so that we
release the conjugate by adding the
hydrating a buffer that is why we call
this L is a like process where we let
the binding of the analyte like that
like the anti antibody to bind to the
test line then when we add the buffer at
the conjugate pole the salt in the
buffer travels faster than the conjugate
and that's why it first washes off all
the uh nonspecific bind bounded proteins
and before the conjugate comes and binds
to the test line that's why these tests
are much more cleaner and more sensitive
and specific and these are also designed
for multiplexing and we will give you
examples of that in the next couple of
slides
what are the advantages of the toolpath
platform first it is sensitive and
specific then lateral flow technology
that's no unwanted in interactions
between conjugate and example there's no
hook effect then it was with multiple
sample matrices for example it works is
over fluid blood serum pass plasma and
stools also we can do pretreatment of
the samples on the sample strip and
we'll give you an example of that later
later on in the presentation and also
multiplexing we can do multiple tests in
one operation and we just need one
sample one one drop of block and the
turnaround time is the same whether you
do a single test or or fighters they
turnaround is just about 15 minutes so
so far what I did is I talked to you
about all the great features of DPP but
how is the sit perform in the field so
the first paper that is published in
Journal of Clinical biology where we did
a multicenter performance evaluation of
DPP HIV want to assay for the detection
of HIV antibodies in various HIV testing
algorithms the goal of the study was to
evaluate the performance of DPP HIV
assay in oral fluids and finger stick
blood in two different situations
countries one is in Nigeria and other is
in the US and then compare the results
to DPP HIV one to test this study
basically contains the about 642
participants from Nigeria which includes
people with high risk low risk and known
HIV positives then from the US it is
done in a clinical environment where you
can group three clinics and two
hospitals we did 2779 participants two
years and older again it also includes
high risk low risk and known HIV
positives what is the protocol for this
death
here I'm showing you two protocols one
is for oral fluid and blood so first
thing is the as I say this system is
flexible and today order in this study
we have shown is there compared the
result from oral fluid and and to that
of blood so let's say for oral fluid
what you do is take a swab and rub it in
the around the gums of your teeth
for four times and put it in a small
this is called a while if you called a
sample trainer this sample trainer has
pre allocated amount of conditioning
agent or what you call the buffer in it
and we add your swab in that and just
mix it it's three times after that you
just add draw two drops of the sample
plus buffer in the intervals wait for
five minutes
and then you add 4 drops of the buffer
in the second well and then wait for 15
minutes and you can't read your results
similarly if you are using for finger
stick blood all you do it's a simple
loop take one loop of blood put it in
the same sample tainer and then the
process is the same
first this you see the robustness second
you see the flexibility of the system if
we have a patient coming in and says I
don't want to do a finger stick blood we
do not have to look for a new test this
test in it you can just say okay let's
do the oral swab around on vice versa
and there's some one more advantage of
the sample trainer which I will address
in the later let's look at the
performance how did this test perform in
the test in Nigeria and the top there
are three rows here the first row
basically talks about DPP tests using
oral fluids second row talk the results
from the fingerstick whole blood and
third one is the standard test but we
are come we are comparing it our results
with a standard already the standard
test in there in the field if you look
at the sincerity ends of the DPP in the
oral fluids you see the it is about 100
percent if we look at in the finger
stick blood it's about 100 percent to
we look at the specificity 100% for oral
fluids and it's also 99.5 percent for
the potency blood the first thing it
shows is that the results the
sensitivity in oral fruits as well as in
the finger stick blood it almost is the
same and and that also the same place
for the specificity to not only that
when we compare the TPP HIV test with
the standard the standard of the market
which is the determine we see that there
are the results are equivalent in short
in Nigeria one thing we have seen in the
nigeria studies he saw that the
sensitivity and specificity are
excellent the next we took this is same
VPP test and did it on samples which
have collected in the u.s. as you see
that the sensitivity of this test is
about ninety eight point nine percent
and about ninety nine point eight
percent puffiness to cold blood and for
specificity it was ninety nine point
nine and hundred percent in with
assistive is fingerstick whole blood as
you see the performance of these tests
either you take in u.s. or nigeria the
performance has been excellent and it's
also comparable to - or where perform
better than the standard in the market
in short what it does what it is is that
it's very clearly showed this test it is
high performing tests both aid and
doesn't matter which part of the world
you are a there you are it in Africa or
in the US this to perform test extremely
well in conclusion we can say that in
the TPP HIV test can detect HIV
antibodies in both oral fluid and
fingerstick when they stick specimen I
talked to me about this DPP sample Taner
this is the bottle where you put either
your swab or your habla a loop or plug
what it does is once you put it inside
this a bottle and you just shake it and
you have the sample in the in a closed
system so nothing can spill that's one
number two is if you want to repeat that
you still have samples lack that is
really important because otherwise you
like to go and pick this patient again
for the sample so this this is a very
important advantage of this sample
trainer system that's a part of the DPP
testing system okay so so far what we
did is we did a lot of talking about the
TPP testing and most of the time I talk
to Jess about HIV testing or a single
testing but we that other needs that we
talked about which said that we needed a
multiplexing we needed on both sampling
conditioning and we also needed to the
multiple sample matrices now in the next
couple of slides all will take through
to the very interesting studies that we
showed how the DPP technology performs
well in all this in detecting all these
different disease conditions word pause
hello everyone my name is Paul Lambert
I am vice president of research and
development that can bio diagnostics a
pleasure to be here and I'm very happy
to introduce you to additional feature
operator e DPP technology we can see
here an expanded version of our DPP
cartridge that Krishnam already
introduced to you in this configuration
we have two test strips instead of one
because we have a sample ads that joins
the two test strips and the sample still
the same from the blood that has been
collected from the patient the sample is
added in the buffer one well and it's
then split between the two strips one on
the top one on the bottom of the drawing
that you can see in front of you so
indirect advantage of this expanded
configuration is that it allows us to
test more analytes innocent from a
single sample the
this multiplex we can have several
several analytes on the top and several
analytes in the bottom and also another
advantage that we discovered is that the
sample can be pretreated in different
fashions depending whether it's going to
the top strip or to the bottom strip for
instance if you want to analyze IgM in
the top and detect I Gigi's in the
bottom you can put some pretreatment
solution that you dry on the sample
strip and that will remove I Gigi's on
the way to the IgM analysis and do the
opposite in the other direction so again
you can see here that the fact that we
are using a separate sample the sample
path to direct the sample to the capture
zone is a real advantage of this DPP
platform by allowing us to remove red
blood cells and to condition and
pretreat the sample before it reaches
its destination here I'm going to talk
for a few minutes about yet another
extension of our technology the portable
and digital reader user is very small it
measures 4 centimeters with 40 grams can
hold in the palm of your hands and yet
it is as sensitive and performing as any
other lateral flow test winner on the
market it is a reflectance reader and as
a reflectance reader it reads the light
that is reflected from the test strip
onto the CCD RA after the to read LEDs
light the strip the pixels on the CCD RA
will collect the photons reflected and
count them and issue
the value of reflectance that is
inversely proportional to the number of
photons collected in the pixels so using
the reader allows us to have a
quantitative application to bartology in
the example that you see on this slide
we calibrate our system so we have now a
correlation between reflectance values a
concentration of analyte in the sample
the results can be expressed as a number
for instance in this case 30 nano grams
per mil that would be the concentration
of the analyte of interest in the sample
and the results can also be reported in
a qualitative way if we use the
thresholds in our interpretation
algorithm the both threshold the result
can be called positive high low reactive
whereas under the threshold the result
can be interpreted as negative or low or
nonreactive so using the reader provides
another dimension to the latter of route
energy that chembio is commercializing
we didn't stop there
we have also finished our optical
analyzers with the possibility of
connecting connectivity is a key word
today everybody is connected we are
connected through I I phones and
computers and we have done the same with
our readers our readers is able to
connect through bluetooth and therefore
result that has been obtained on the
reader can be printed directly on the
Bluetooth printer the reader can
transfer the results through a PC or to
a an iPhone or a cell phone
the reader can do that also using a USB
cable so the results go to the iPhone go
to the PC and can be transmitted to the
cloud for further use by combining our
test cartridges with a reader we obtain
what we took the de system and the DPD
system is the latest evolution of our
platform and they include a DPP test
either a single window cartridge single
pegs or as you can see in the middle
cartridge a duplex test or more highly
multiplex test when we use our expanded
cartridges with two test strips and to
test test windows we have therefore
developed a second generation reader
which is the one you can see there on
the bottom of the slide this feeder is
able to read a single cartridge or a
cartridge with two windows and we will
see later how this can be very
advantageous when you need to read a
test that has up to eight analytes and
each results coming from it so let's
look now at applications of the DPP
technology you already heard Krishnan
and saw single assay applications like
the one that he presented for the DPP
HIV 1 & 2 system he also mentioned the
DPP HIV syphilis which is a duplex test
for dual assay and I just showed you a
cartridge with two test windows that can
handle up to eight analytes
if we look at singular say applications
the DPP Zika assay the Zika AGM system
is the world's fastest Zika test it is
the first
rapid lateral flow test that was
approved by the FDA under emergency use
authorization of Zika IgM in patients
blood it's a 15 minute test that works
like Krishnan presented to you before
three simple steps prepare the sample
run the test and read the result it
works with blood serum and plasma and
the DPP micro reader will provide
results in as short as three seconds
this is an illustration of the three
steps that shows how easily the test is
being performed and on the slides here
we can see how the test is being
interpreted the reader includes an
algorithm that is assay specific and is
stored on an RFID chip this chip can be
on a separate card or this chip can be
integrated into the test cartridge so
that when it's the cartridge is
presented to the reader the reader can
immediately know what kind of assay is
on the cartridge and how it's going to
interpret the signals that the
reflectance will give it so in this case
for instance the results that are read
to interpret the DPP Zika IGF test will
be seen as Z for Zika IgM because it's
really in the IgM signal then it will
show a number if the number is under the
cutoff of 20 in this case four on three
it would be followed by the letters and
an R for nonreactive and if the assay is
positive the signal will be higher than
the cutoff and the results will show in
this case 230 and R for reactive in the
case there would have been a technical
problem with running the test and if the
test line was not there or was too faint
then the result would be considered
invalid and the reader will report the
three letters
nv4 invalid the DPP Zika IgM system as I
said earlier is the first repeat test
that has been approved for emergency use
authorization by the FDA the test has
been compared to other tests that also
have been received the EU a
authorization from the FDA those tests
called one two and three in this
illustration here are laboratory based
and are performed on automated
instruments and yes this handheld and
performed manually performed and read
with a small reader test performs as you
can see on the graph on the left as well
if not better than those three clinical
lab based tests and you can see that the
performance between eight days and 83
days after the disease onset the
performance of the DPP Zika IgM is 99.7%
percent in sensitivity compared to
beit's 90.2 and 93.3 for the three other
tests so this does of the DPP platform
can be highly performing and the results
that we obtained with this DK IG and
system are also at the same level as
those that were obtained with the HIV
test which was with sensitivity very
close to 100% for sensitivity and
specificity now again this test is
approved for emergency use authorization
it's not the 510 K we are working on
this but it has some limitations of
where on where it can be used and how it
can be used another example of
application of our DPP platform is for
multiplex in this case dual test for HIV
and syphilis from a single blood drop a
drop of blood from the patient and in a
single test performance so you can see
the DPP cartridge here we to the slides
called one and two one for HIV 1 for C
phase and the control life after running
the test the cartridge is inserted in
the DPP holder the button is pressed on
the top of the reader and in three
seconds the reader results are displayed
very easy again collect the sample
introduce it in the same container shake
it load it in the sample well with five
minutes of the buffer and 10 minutes
later the results can be read duplex
test for HIV and syphilis is very needed
for several reasons there is a brief
there is an increase of this case in the
West and in the whole world whereas the
disease was almost eradicated ten years
ago from open from the US and if
syphilis is very often diagnosed and
present in individuals who are at high
risk of syphilis and HIV infection so it
makes sense to have an HIV and syphilis
assay that can be used with the
high-risk population so here we offer a
test that is very patient friendly you
take only one drop of blood we have to
assess in singular operation for the
technologist and the test user it's only
easier since it's only one operation
that we give two results it's very
reliable because we use a reader to read
the
and it turns out that lateral flow test
in general can be difficult to interpret
when the test lines are very faint and
it's a natural tendency of the human
readers to prefer coding test negative
when the test line is barely visible and
yet if it is visible it's a positive
test the reader will not make that
mistake the reader will just look at the
cutoff and if the reader value is higher
than the cutoff that that's really
called positive so using a reader is
very useful again to prevent subjective
analysis and interpretation of the
results this test will be very suitable
for programs to prevent mother-to-child
transmission and to support the fight
against the rising syphilis infection in
high-risk patients as you can see this
is very important to note that the
performance of this duplex test is as
good as the performance of separate HIV
and syphilis test 99.9% sensitivity and
100% on various whole blood and plasma
and for HIV syphilis 100% finger stick
blood and 99% and 100% of serum venous
or blood and plasma the test has been
used outside of the US for several years
and many studies have been performed and
in the two slides that I'm going to show
you now we are going to look at the
results of meta-analysis of laboratory
and field studies of this test in
various countries a studies were
performed shown by the CDC song by the
University of California Los Angeles in
Brazil makes
sico peru jana and malawi seven of those
studies didn't use the reader at the
time the results were interpreted
visually after we introduced the reader
the age study was performed and used
both the visual interpretation and
reader based interpretation below me for
a comparison of the two interpretation
methods you can see the tables on this
slide that show the results obtained for
each of the eight studies and under the
tables the aggregated sensitivity and
specificity of the studies for HIV
ninety-nine point fourteen percent
sensitivity and ninety-eight point 82
percent specificity and for syphilis
ninety six twenty four percent
sensitivity in ninety nine point five
nine percent specificity so those
results again in an aggregated form
confirm all the results that have been
shown in the previous slides of this
presentation of the two tables at the
bottom we can see the results obtained
with the reader and again for HIV they
are very well in line with the
aggregated results that I just presented
for syphilis
it looks like the sensitivity is a
little lower but we're talking about one
false positive sample on 142 samples
total and that may be due to various
reasons maybe one being that it was the
first time that we were using the reader
in the field and when we look at the
specificity it is as good as the one
obtained with visual results so overall
we can say that the result obtained by
the reader are similar to those obtained
visually
in conclusion a combination repeat test
for the detection of antibodies to HIV
and to syphilis at the point-of-care
works very well and as well as separate
tests and it delivers the same levels of
sensitivity and specificity the two dose
of separate repeat tests now let's look
for a few moments and highly multiplexed
rapid tests here for the detection of
pathogens that provoke similar symptoms
of fever in due to several diseases and
in this case it's the DPP fever I know
for Africa the seven pathogens include
Ebola Lhasa and Marburg which are three
deadly diseases chikungunya dengue and
Zika which are also endemic to Africa
and malaria which is also found in the
same areas where Ebola Lhasa and Marburg
are found it's very important to put all
those seven pathogens on the same test
because at the beginning at the onset of
the disease those seven pathogens
present with the same symptoms in
patients and so it's very difficult to
diagnose those diseases based on
symptoms only and as you can understand
it's very important when you triage
patients in a zone where Ebola is
present for instance that you can
discriminate very rapidly and
efficiently between Ebola and let's say
malaria so that we say the patient's can
be separated and treated differently the
results will be interpreted with the DPP
micro reader to provide an objective
read of the result and avoid any
misinterpretation by the users and also
because when you have a cartridge with a
number of the slides on the same string
you want to be sure that there is no
transcription error by reading multiple
tests from multiple lines that are
close to each other in this slide we
show the results from a study that was
aimed at analyzing the performance of
the malaria component of the multiplex
test we have made several studies and
during each of the study we analyzed
separates analytes like Ebola
for instance in malaria so in this case
we see the results from a malaria study
which took place both in Africa and in
Peru in South America and you can see on
the table on the right that the two
components for malaria the HRP protein
and the pea LDH analyte give as good if
not better performance as those obtained
with w-h-o pre-qualified malaria rapid
diagnostic tests 98.6% of the samples
were detected by H R P 2 and 4 p LD h
which we know is a lower performing
analyte we were very close to 80%
performance we are working hard on
creating more applications of the DPP
technology so that are those assays can
be used in the field and can be used on
millions of people who need them in the
areas where malaria dengue chikungunya
are endemic and you can see here several
examples of the the expanded format with
the two test test strips or the single
format on the bottom line you can see
examples of DBP zika tests looking for
IgM presence on the top window and IgG
presence in the bottom window same for
dengue or chikungunya and on the right
you can see a cassette that includes the
tree DPB zika chikungunya and dengue IgM
and I di Gigi detection test on the
bottom you can see antigen test so in
this case we're not looking at the IgM
presence or AGG but the antigens to zika
dengue and chikungunya on a single
cartridge or dengue and a swamp antigen
or again IgM only for zika dengue and
chikungunya or Zika by itself each of
those combinations has it's particularly
important feel field of interest by the
various countries and various regions
they can be used in areas where some
disease is endemic or where there is an
outbreak or they can be used like the
DPP's de Cadenet chikungunya combination
test for APD epidemiological studies so
in conclusion I think that Kristin and I
have presented to you the next
generation of lateral flow test the
generation that allows for high
performance high sensitivity
quantitation connectivity and
multiplexing and by combining together
the power of the DPP lateral flow
technology with multiplexing and with
the benefit of a reader we are we are
able to offer who are customers and to
millions of patients the DPP system I
want to thank you for being with us
today and if you have any questions we
will feel free to send them to us and we
will reply to you via email thank you
very much